hey leute was klappt herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video ich hoffe ihr habt mich
gerade ich habe gerade eine neue kamera
auf jeden fall geht es heute nach köln
zum justin bieber konzert irgendwie darf
ich da hin weil ich auch nicht warum
und ich nehme euch mit ich hoffe ich bin
gar nicht zu hell jetzt geht's erst mal
ab hinzu bis gleich bis auf jeden fall
geht es heute nach köln heute ist der
achtzehnte 18 september
und ja ich darf heute mit meinem
netzwerk zusammen aus dass die miba
konzern in eine schöne lose dass wir
bestimmt super toll ich freue mich so
sehr und mein ganzes leben morgen schule
also leute heute wie gesagt jetzt habe
ich zeit ist kann ich ein bisschen
mitreden
ich darf heute nach köln was heißt ich
darf also ist es folgendes passiert an
sich so ich bin jetzt nicht der größte
justin bieber fan aber ich finde ihn so
ganz cool und ich wollte eigentlich
nicht aufs konzert gehen dann kam
allerdings die freundin von mir zu mir
und meinte ich habe eine karte kannst du
vielleicht irgendwie verkaufen oder
verlosen so weil sie halt nicht konnte
und da habe ich gedacht also schöne
grüße an antonia jetzt hab ich dich auch
mal gegrüßt
auf jeden fall habe ich gedacht kann es
eigentlich auch selber gehen und dann
hatte ich vor halt selber zu gehen
allerdings kann mein netzwerk auf mich
zu und hat gesagt ja du kannst auch mit
uns kommen wir haben da so einen lounge
und habe gedacht die gerne und hatte
dann halt ne auf jeden fall abstand
halten karte über und habe mir gedacht
wir kommen verlost jedoch einfach bei
instagram oder so habe ich dann auch
gemacht ja doch jemand gewonnen mit dem
traffic light beziehungsweise mit ihr
treffe ich mich gleich schöne grüße an
marie heißt du glauben und da auch mal
wirklich sorry dass ich nur eine karte
verlosen konnte ich meinen armen
wirklich so viele daran teilgenommen und
ich wusste gar nicht wenig nehmen soll
ich wollte denen dann drehen dann doch
lieber den und jetzt halt die liebe
marie gewonnen wie gesagt mit der 34
mich gleich und ich will es gar nicht
mehr um erzählen ich nehme ich jetzt
einfach mit ich bin hat in hamm ein auch
wie das kind haben in westfalen und
warte auf meine ec und dann geht's
schnell nach köln hoffe ich bis gleich
hieß
mit
hey
so leute wir sind jetzt in köln
angekommen beziehungsweise ich auf jeden
fall ist richtig cool hier schlafen ich
heute das ganze in seiner loge zeigen
dies eine cola stimme kurz auf
was ist das da
okay ich habe sie aber nicht das ist
das hängt
wertberichtigt
alkoholische getränke weil es für mich
bestimmt dankeschön und
das war ich sage ich mal wie das
aussieht von hier und das licht ist sehr
blau arbeitest du cool aus
die bühne sieht man kaum aber
es ist so viel ich finde es cool
dankeschön
lieber
die trainer alle komplett am rad ist
nummer natürlich ist logisch aber ist
nochmal eine stufe härter als auch so
youtube veranstaltungen obwohl ich das
ja schon immer krass findet
naja ich bin jetzt war gespannt und ich
lass mich überraschen und machst du so
passiert hieß
ich bin zum ersten mal in meinem leben
dass essent
ich glaube es sind kartoffeln ist sicher
hallo auf jeden fall beginnt jetzt
gleich ich bin richtig nervös hatte
heftig wirklich gespannt auf die chance
ich freue mich immer fasziniert
ja ich weiß wir haben auch das
kanzleramt
was das thema getroffen nach
sie kommt
diese
nein
lima
sein
b
hey leute gebt euch mal dass jemand
vorsätzlich die haben ja einfach die
haben ja einfach seit freitag
übernachtet nur in der ersten reihe zu
stehen
irgendwie kanisters wollen wir auch eine
tour machen so dass vielleicht auch zwei
die schreiben sie hatten kein ticket
aber hier seit fünf uhr morgens was denn
los sei
die krank heftig leute das war's mit
diesem blog ich hoffe natürlich er hat
euch gefallen als es der fall war würde
ich mich jetzt mega übernahmen nach oben
freuen eine positive bewertung was
versprochen auf jeden fall was für mich
eine coole erfahrung irgendwie mal auf
dem konzert zu sein war ich vorher noch
nie war eine coole show er hat
vielleicht nicht ganz so viel gesungen
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe sondern
mehr ein bisschen getanzt aber warum
nicht so ist das anscheinend wusste ich
auch nicht aber gut wir sehen uns am
donnerstag um 18 uhr beim neuen video
das dürft ihr auf keinen fall verpassen
und bis dahin könnt ihr gerne auch auf
empfehlung folgen alex w